it's great to welcome to the program
today Eric Coffman who is professor of
politics at Birkbeck University of
London in the UK also author of white
shift its populism immigration and the
future of white majorities Eric great to
have you on today great to be here David
so let's I mean how what's the best way
when someone doesn't know about the
discussions that are taking place in
political circles and anthropological
circles in many circles about the future
of race divisions or sort of the racial
makeup of modern Western countries
including the United States what is the
kind of top-line change that we're
seeing and what we expect racial makeup
to look like in twenty-five and fifty
years
well many many Americans are obviously
familiar with the figure of roughly half
of Americans won't be non-hispanic
whites around 2050 that's that's been
known for a while well less well known
is that something similar will occur
around the same time in Canada and New
Zealand the changes in Canada which is
where I'm originally from are actually
quite dramatic some statistics Canada
demographers showed that in 2006 the
population was about 80% white 20%
minority and then by 2106 a hundred
years later the proportions are more or
less reversed kind of give you it now
Canada is one of the faster-moving
countries but it gives you a sense of
the changes were we're really only now
embarking on and that we're really going
to reverberate around the West in Europe
it will be towards the end of the
century at least in Western Europe that
the majority-minority point will will
arrive but this is these are just a
sense of set of quite monumental shifts
that are gonna change our politics in
great ways so what has been the sort of
political reaction as people learn about
this coming change across countries I
mean I know that in the United States
there's definitely a right-wing element
that sees this as evidence that whites
are or soon will be an oppressed
minority potentially this leads to
arguments about what immigration policy
should be it stems and connects
from and connects to a lot of other sort
of policy issues but is there some
general way in which this shift is being
sort of interpreted by left and right
wing elements of the different countries
you mentioned yeah I think that there is
a general pattern the the response
amongst conservatives is one of identity
threat I think which is what's
fundamentally driving right-wing
populism I think across Europe and also
in the US and elsewhere I think on the
left there is an element of the left
that is sort of seizing upon this as a
sort of signal or Harbinger that some
kind of new society is emerging and it's
sort of in bold embolden akai to
multi-cultural what I would think is
almost a millenarian view of the new
society that's going to emerge sort of
diverse and equal and I think you've got
a clash of these two visions that's
taking place and so part of this is not
just the rise of right-wing populism but
also value polarization as these visions
clash can you talk about that a little
bit when you say value polarization I
think most people understand what values
are and they understand polarization but
what what are we talking about more
specifically when values become
polarized yeah essentially what we know
from political psychology is that there
are sort of deep rooted dispositions
that people have quite bluntly
essentially some people prefer diversity
difference change other people prefer
order continuity the present to be like
the past that that is sort of between a
third and a half heritable if we look at
the literature on psychological
authoritarianism or status quo
conservatism by people like Karen stem
Stenner and what this means therefore is
that as we see these demographic shifts
they're going to be processed very
differently by people who are
psychologically more conservative and
those who are more you know open to
change or who score high on something
like that the Big Five tray of openness
to experience so what we're seeing then
is this divide some have called it open
closed some Akali
somewhere is any where's that cultural
value divide is reordering Paul
it's splitting political parties that
were initially formed on the basis of
left versus right which are economic
orientations around lower tax more
redistribution that that older economic
cleavage and politics is being overlaid
by this stronger kind of open/close type
cleavage yeah Jonathan Hite has some
interesting work along these lines as
well who he's probably the the person
who I've read most recently on these
ideas of values now do the values carry
so let's back up a little bit there have
been a lot of discussions that I've had
on the program about how at face value
it doesn't necessarily correlate that a
political contingent that is for low
taxes would necessarily also be against
abortion for example and worried about
so-called oppression against whites as a
result the result of demographic shifts
like it doesn't appear that there is
anything obvious that is sort of weaving
those positions together into a defined
political constituency but is there
actually something sort of underneath
the surface that does inform why those
political positions end up sort of as
part of the same voting bloc or or is
there not well yeah you can get
ideological construction whereby
positions which probably don't
necessarily align on the sort of
psychological level such as free markets
and restricted immigration it's not
obvious that those two things go
together at all but you will have an
ideological package that's created by a
right-wing political party or a
left-wing political party they will yoke
together things that may not fit either
philosophically or psychologically what
I would say however is that the
pressures from these sort of
psychological values groups can
reconfigure parties so far-right parties
in Europe which used to be more low-tax
have shifted more in the direction of
welfare state welfare protectionism even
in the u.s. you saw that one of the big
predictors of Trump supporters as
opposed to support for other primary
candidates was actually a relatively
more liberal attitude to things like
Medicare
so that's sort of economically slightly
to the left but culturally very
concerned about immigration that group
fractured the Republican Party to some
extent so I think even though yes
parties do provide these menus of
options which are in many ways don't fit
together very well you can get these
movements that fracture that and create
new orientations amongst the parties so
yeah it's probably about how the
political actors slaught into it fit
into these dispositions I mean so you
could have imagined it could be war on
terror that could be mobilizing that
that sort of order seeking disposition
amongst voters but then when the war on
terror of the Cold War fades another
division might be mobilized it might be
the border for example so there are
different ways of plugging into these
dispositions the dispositions are
somewhat nonspecific one thing we know
however is certainly immigration
attitudes are heavily extremely heavily
correlated with these value dispositions
I mean I've looked at British and US
data and views on for example the death
penalty views on whether things in let's
say things in America were better in the
past especially American culture was
better in the past that has a very very
strong link to immigration attitudes so
I think it's these some psychological
dispositions which underlie the
immigration attitudes which underlie
this or populist politics and the
polarization the polarization also
arises when the kind of left liberal
side reacts to the populist right side
and thinks they are morally retrograde
and there's I think a whole debate there
but that reaction to the rise of the
populist right that provides in addition
to people responding differently to the
stimulus of diversity you also have this
value division over is it even
legitimate to have a conversation about
obstructing immigration so that adds
just another layer to this polarizing
dynamic it's its most extreme in America
but we saw in the European elections
recently that in Europe both the
populist right and the green and liberal
parties scored better than they ever
have so that's kind of suggesting Europe
is kind of moving in that polarizing
direction so Eric when it comes
to the possible grievances that one
could have um sort of under the umbrella
of right-wing populism with this racial
shift that we are starting to see with
the idea of possibly losing status which
we know was a great motivator for some
Trump voters in 2016 if you had to sort
of steal man as much as possible to make
the best possible case that some or one
of those grievances is sort of backed in
historical realities or empirical
realities do any of those grievances
stand up I actually think they do and
this may be a place we might disagree is
this I think that there's a real
difference in the survey data for
example and in psychological literature
between hatred of out-groups kin racism
and attachment to own group
now attachment to own group can also
lead to racism if it leads you to
discriminate but I think there's an
important distinction there so people
can be attached to being a member of an
ethnic majority group like white
American or white British they can be
attached to a particular configuration
of nationhood with a ethnic majority and
minority groups but with a particular
share for each and want to conserve that
so that's kind of a conservative
orientation based on attachment which is
I think different from fearing or hating
and out-group or wanting to oppress an
out group or wanting to keep power so I
think that somehow I would would state a
lot of the in participant of course
there are racists you know you know most
of the populous right voters that
clearly are gonna be people who simply
you know hate Muslims or or hate
Hispanics or whatever the other area so
so absolutely but there's also we know
from certainly from Ashley giardina's
work for example on white identity
politics a lot of voters for example
white Americans who feel warmer towards
whites do not feel cooler towards blacks
let's say or Hispanics then whites who
don't particularly feel warm towards
whites so the warmth towards one's own
group doesn't correlate with hostility
to the out-group and I think a lot of
there are a lot of people who are
attached to their
Grouper attached to their own way of
life and it's not that different
actually from african-americans in
Harlem attached to Harlem's
african-american majority and so the
question is what we do about that I
think well before we even get to what to
do about I mean let me make sure I
understand that because this is an
interesting point if I understand you
correctly you're saying that you can
sort of rank people based on the level
of attachment they have to their group
so for example we can take white people
in the United States or as they like to
call them Europe he to call themselves
in some groups European Americans so to
speak that you might have one cohort
that has significant sort of attachment
and pride connected to being a white
American and another cohort which has
less pride or attachment to being a
white American but that both of those
groups would end up having a sort of
statistically similar feeling towards
other groups like black Americans or
Hispanic Americans or whoever that in
other words the level of attachment to
your group is not necessarily zero-sum
when compared to your feeling towards
other groups right exactly yeah that's
quite different say from partisan
identity where if you're a conservative
and you're attached to being
conservative you have a cooler feeling
towards a liberal so that's much more of
a zero-sum type of identity I guess
where it becomes politically relevant is
well that may be correct me if I'm wrong
while at the sort of large scale in the
aggregate that maybe my sense is and
maybe there is data to back this up that
those who choose to become activists
around keeping the country white are
probably skewed on one side of those
results in terms of how they feel
towards those in the out-group versus
those who say you know my choice of
activism is not going to be around
keeping the country white it's going to
be around for example increasing access
to health care I'm guessing that there
you would see some dividing lines in
terms of feelings towards out groups
yeah I mean I think in the radical
segments like the KKK you definitely
would have uh you know high white
identity and strong hostility to out
groups
but I think that I would caution against
simply dismissing the conservative
element I mean it's not so different
from wanting to conserve you know
historic building or historic landmarks
or a way of life I mean that it is going
to get expressed somehow and I think it
would be better to talk about how quick
should we have this rate of cultural
change how can the majority adapt one of
the things that I say in my book is if
majorities can be more open to
intermarry interracial marriage and
adopting of mixed-race people into their
group this is a way forward because I
think you have to give the ethnic
majority a vision of itself in the
future if it's just about your the bad
old past your toxic you've got a decline
I don't think that's gonna I think
that's gonna lead to more polarization
so I think talking about melting the
group maintaining itself through through
interracial marriage I think is one one
way forward I know that's not gonna be
accepted by all members yeah well I mean
it sounds like to some degree you're
saying that there needs to be some level
of appeasement at least of the fear that
is there regardless of what it is that
is motivating that fear that from a
pragmatic standpoint which I like to try
to take with a lot of these issues that
just saying hey this is the way it's
going to be and that's it is not a good
path forward from a pragmatic
perspective but that's some degree of
appeasement and I don't use that word in
a negative way is a probably a positive
thing yeah I mean I would call it
appeasement so much as a kind of
reassurance and not not so much about
I'm not convinced that it's about fear
of loss of power so much I mean if you
look at Europe where these groups are
more dominant in terms you know ninety
percent of the population it's not
really about that as much as I think a
loss of this attachment to the way
things were the country they knew
growing up it's not the country they
recognize anymore that kind of
psychological dissonance is more the
issue and I think one way of come
getting around that is to talk through
how the consciousness the myths of
ancestry traditions can continue through
through a mixed-race population as well
which I'm arguing that these white
majorities will become over time that
kind of
to use my Glen's term I think
stigmatizing these groups and trying to
sort of frame them as the past and it's
something we have to supersede that's
been a mistake amongst some progressive
actors so I think I would prefer to be a
more conciliatory move that allows each
group to come habits identity rather
than trying to toxify one identity very
very interesting stuff we've been
speaking with Professor Eric Coffman
professor of politics at Birkbeck
University of London in the UK also
author of the book white shift populism
immigration and the future of white
majorities Eric really appreciate your
time today thanks very much David